comme je l'ai dit moi je suis en secteur
2 je fais plus de la moitié de mon
activité au tarif Sécu
le motif de leur grogne l'accord sur le
dépassement d'honoraires signés fin
octobre par 3 syndicats la ministre de
la Santé les accusent de tous les mots
et ce n'est pas admissible pour eux moi
je suis en secteur 2 je suis chirurgien
de la main j'ai créé ici à Trappes à
l'hôpital privé de l'Est parisien un des
plus gros centre sosman france j'exerce
mon activité à plus de 55% au tarif
opposable 55% des gens qui viennent me
voir n'ont pas un centime à débourser
pour leurs soins alors on est en train
d'expliquer au médecin qui comme moi en
secteur 2 font plus de la moitié de leur
activité au tarif opposable qui
travaillent pas bien mais c'est quoi ce
délire la ministre accuse les médecins
d'être responsables d'un mal-être social
alors que nous nous sommes les soignants
c'est nous qui soignons les Français
c'est nous qui nous occupons de alors
s'il y a des problèmes de remboursement
des Français c'est pas de notre faute
c'est pas nous qui fonctionnent les
tarifs opposables c'est pas nous qui
fixons les tarifs des assurances
complémentaires oui il y a des
compléments d'honoraires oui quelques
médecins quelques dizaines de médecins
français font des compléments qui sont
au-delà de ce qui pourrait être
recommandable très bien le Conseil de
l'Ordre et là pour faire le ménage
attrape malgré le taux de grévistes la
continuité des soins est assurée et les
patients nouvellement arrivés transférés
vers d'autres établissements le
mouvement a démarré sur les réseaux
sociaux il y a 3 semaines et sur le
terrain depuis ce lundi la grève est
illimitée et mercredi Christian
couturier et a manifesté à Paris devant
le ministère de la Santé